hey what's up guys so today we're
looking at Emma sighs r-tx 2080 gaming
extra which is their flagship cooling
design for the RT X series now in my
last video we looked at how the RT X
2080 itself performs in games against
current offerings like the GT X 1080 TI
and the 1080 and the basic conclusion
there was basically to save yourself the
100 or 150 US dollars and go with the
1080 Ti the reason for this is that they
perform basically the same in non RT X
games and since there's no RT X titles
actually published for playing at the
moment it makes it very difficult to
guess what the performance will be like
there so yes this card will have the
potential to do real-time ray tracing
and perform deep learning operations
like a dll SS but only for a handful of
games that support those effects we will
be testing this when they're finally
implemented so in this video we will be
looking at the gaming exterior
exclusively and this card seems to be
one of the more popular options during
this RT X launch among some of the other
options and we're going to be looking at
calling design thermals and of course
overclocking as well but first let's
talk about a few details that you should
probably know before buying this card
now one of the most important details
here is the size as this directly
affects compatibility in your current
case and like the majority of our 2x
cards the gaming extra is not small it's
two and a half slots 345 millimeters
long including the i/o bracket and 140
millimeters tall as the name suggests
there are three fans on the trio 185 not
near fan on the left and two 95
millimeter fans on the right all three
fans remain idle until the GPU
temperature is 58 degrees C at which
point two fans on the right will kick in
in the 85 millimeter fan will kick in
about a minute or two after I'm guessing
when the memory temperature is a certain
threshold I mentioned this in my
teardown video of the card but the fan
on the left is smaller and is offset
downwards to make the NV link connection
compatible with other cards now there
are a few benefits to the fans being
inactive under a certain temperature
threshold first of course is noise and
if you're not gaming you want to hear
anything coming from a graphics card at
all and the second is improved lifespan
of those fans if you plan on keeping the
card for more than
couple years personally I think a
threshold of 58 degrees C is a bit too
high as it means potentially that your
GPU could be idling at 57 degrees C when
it's not in use and although there's
nothing really wrong with that I'd
personally just rather have the fence
spin at around 500 rpm just to bring
that idle temp down a little bit luckily
though idle temps for this model are in
check at 36 degrees C at an ambient of
20 but just keep that temperature
threshold in mind I've seen other
manufacturers start to do this as well
and the threshold just seems to be
getting higher and higher on a visual
note I think the gaming exterior looks
pretty good and it's definitely a breath
of fresh air from MSI as it looks like
they're catching on to the mixed
feedback of their previous red and black
color scheme the trigger is entirely
neutral except for a couple red
highlights here in there and powering up
the card shows a ton of RGB you've got
three RGB elements at the top of the
card and another two at the bottom and
it does come configured as a rainbow out
of the box I tried playing around with
the lining but the current version of
MSI's mystic light software doesn't seem
to work with the Arctic series just yet
so hopefully we can get an update for
that quiet soon same situation with MSI
Afterburner as well I couldn't see any
fan rpm values and the voltage slider
was completely grayed out EVGA is
precision XOC at least had the V call
offset slider enabled but it didn't seem
to do anything as the V call constantly
remained at one point over five volts
the card is powered by two eight pin
connectors which is a step up over the
eight plus six pin connectors on the
founder's edition RTX 2080
not that it makes a real difference to
invidious restriction to overclocking
the backplate is a brushed aluminum that
looks quite nice
again I can definitely appreciate the
direction that MSI taking here by making
the design a lot more neutral and build
friendly the back plate does soak up
quite a bit of heat as well since there
are thermal pads between it and the PCV
and I measured just over 49 degree C on
top of the back plate over the GPU I was
surprised to see no thermal pads on the
underside of the vrm though but luckily
that's not needed as we'll see in just a
minute
disassembling the card is pretty
straightforward with all screws
accessible via the backplate the small
backplate screws are what you want to
remove first and the backplate should
come straight off then only the heatsink
screws are left there's four four pin
connectors that you'll need to
plug and now we can just take a look at
that massive heatsink so the cold plate
for the GPU die is attached to six
nickel plated copper heat pipes that
feed directly into that dense fin stack
and all the components of the vrm are in
direct contact to a cold plate
underneath the heatsink the memory gets
its own base plate here which is secured
by two screws besides the display
outputs but there's no contact between
this plate and the heat sink the vcore
vrm seems to be a true 12 phase layer
although I can't confirm that 100% the
PWM controller is the MP to 888 but I
can't find any data sheets online on
this one but there doesn't seem to be
any double is on the PCB so it looks
like a true 12 face if anyone has more
info here feel free to drop that down
below if it is a true 12 phase though
we're looking at an extra two phases
over in videos found edition RTX 2080
okay now let's talk about thermals as
you'd expect these to be pretty decent
with a caller that big out of the box
the gaming exterior will sit happily at
65 degrees C during full load at a fan
speed of just one thousand rpm in the
vrm and memory temps were in check as
well
these were measured with a k-type
thermocouple since there were no sensors
on the board noise levels were pretty
outstanding as well I attempted to
measure these with the current test
bench setup but most of the noise was
coming from my AIO you'll have to take
my word here that it was whisper quiet
but seeing it was at 1,000 rpm or full
load that's probably not hard to believe
now overclocking was a bit of a mixed
bag as I said I couldn't seem to raise
the vcore at all and whether or not I
had the vehicle offset slider maxed out
or not imprecision XOC the vehicle just
set constantly at around 1.5 volts the
power limit was also quite low at 109
percent although power levels sent
pretty comfortably under 100% and in the
end I was able to add 150 mega Hertz to
the GPU and a massive 950 megahertz to
the memory now these offsets gave us an
effective GPU clock of 2100 megahertz
and a memory clock of 7950
and this yield is a pretty significant
boost in gaming of just over 10% here on
average in Warhammer vermintide 2 again
although the superior vrm does help you
it mostly comes down to the quality of
that GPU thermals were pretty decent too
even with the overclock in place but
you'd expect that since there was no
difference in the GPU voltage of
clocking is definitely recommended in
this instance since there's a ton of
cooling Headroom available for the GPU
memory and MOSFETs but keep in mind that
you may not be able to achieve such a
significant offset as I did here as that
will come down to the GPU and memory
modules that happen to be paired with
this board so overall this is a really
solid board if you're considering the
r-tx 2080 now we all know pricing is
very inflated compared to the reference
pricing of $699 that via announced
during the RT x launch the majority of
RT x 2080s can be found sitting around
800 to 850 with the gaming exterior
towards the upper end of that price
bracket but rightfully so because you
are absolutely getting your money's
worth here in terms of additional
cooling and reduced noise levels the
1080 Ti remains the much better option
in my opinion as it performs identically
to the RT X 2080 but for 100 to 150 US
dollars less at least in the titles that
we have available to test today
I do understand though that some of you
will insist on buying the RT X 2080 and
however you rationalize that is
completely up to you maybe you want to
tinker around with RT X when it's
finally implemented in games or maybe
the price difference between the RT x
2080 and the 1080i isn't a significant
difference in your region either way the
gaming extra is a very solid option
especially in terms of thermals and
noise it's hard to see how anyone could
be disappointed with this card so guys
let me know your thoughts down below
subscribe if you haven't already and as
always I'll see you all in the next one